all right well since it's thursday you
know what that means it's time to break
down everything from last night's insane
episode of survivor 42. yeah and this
episode was filled with shifting targets
major trust issues and a huge twist that
sent one cast away packing spoiler alert
you're about to find out who yeah yeah
and i think we can all agree that their
exit was
do you think was one of the most iconic
of the season you said it i think so
take a look
lindsay i'm rooting for you you know why
thank you jonathan believe it or not
you were never on my radar but you're
always after me
mike if you make it to the end you'll
probably win
thank you kiss of death
romeo you've been on the block every
time omar you're the only person i told
the secret to and i want everyone else
to know that
marianne keep being you babe thank you
you gave me two i lied
and now of course we're joined by our
very own survivor correspondent and
season 41 winner erica hey girl hi
morgan hey cheryl it's girls day on et
canada live yeah i love it
and i'm ready to share all of the
insights on last night's crazy episode
perfect so as we saw drea was sent to
the jury last night and oh my gosh her
exit speech was all the things erica
what
are your thoughts on her statements at
tribal
drea really took the opportunity these
were her last few moments in the game
where she could talk and she went for it
so she said she thought that mike was
going to be the biggest threat to win at
the end and she said that omar was the
one who shared the information about her
advantage and i feel like a lot of the
times when players do this it's because
you know they just got voted out they
just wanted to have that one last bit of
impact on the game and i don't blame
draya for doing this good for her okay
well as we know obviously she didn't go
without a fight but before she had the
chance to use her multiple advantages
lindsay was faced with a twist from last
season that put her entire game in the
hands of the survivor gods yes the do or
die twist was brought back for season 42
with jeff announcing that whoever opted
to compete in this week's immunity
challenge could possibly face
consequences erica explain to you this
or explain this to all of us what
exactly went down well with the do or
die twist if you decide to participate
in the immunity challenge you are able
to potentially win immunity but if you
fall first then you have to play this
game of chance at tribal council and
might get eliminated by a weird game of
chance
and this season only two people jonathan
and lindsey opted to play the challenge
and then lindsay
lost and had to do the do or die luckily
she didn't die lindsay lived and i've
got to say
i hate this twist i said it to jeff
while i was filming survivor 41 i don't
like it i think that i can appreciate we
need twists and advantages to shake up
the game but often the players get a
chance to get a twist and then they can
figure out with their wit how to
strategically or socially move around it
do or die just makes it into a weird
casino game i feel like jeff could walk
into tribal council with three cups in a
ball and move them around and then guess
where the ball is i think the only good
thing about the do or die twist is there
is a clip of me in the episode
erica is speaking her truth i love it
okay so lastly honestly that was
hilarious we have to talk about drea
using her knowledge as power advantage
unsuccessfully
yes she mistakenly told omar that she
was going to steal mike's immunity idol
with her advantage only for omar to blab
and to convince him to hand over the
idol so they could actually flesh out
drea's advantage and then vote her out
and it's so interesting because i think
this speaks to the human nature of it
all this advantage is designed for
people to keep it a secret and even in a
game like survivor where it's high
stakes there's a million dollars people
are social they want to share their
advantages with everybody else and
unfortunately
that didn't play out well for drea this
season